welcome to this video chris m who is
that new account ok so g for novelty it
takes know okay so yeah d6 i goone idea
three I don't like c-45 for wide that
much so I'm going with 90 of three NC
form yeah it's very likely to transpose
into some Kings Indian yeah or this one
it's also possible how is he going to
pledge night bt7 harm yeah yeah I might
be tempted to play your form after night
BTW 7 there's not much that he can do in
terms of weight let's let's not be too
quick here d 595 slightly awkward may
not already but I can do this first I
mean I don't really feel that she takes
on deform just play but should be too
and break the pin now after future d 595
I can go I'm Bishop 9201 so let's
develop and now I'm really ready for d
phi f if I really want to play that move
Jung kt5 or not interesting question I'm
going for it I always like to have the
space however you can certainly argue
that giving our releasing this tension
might not be the best possible
continuation that certainly certainly an
argument you can make camp playing g3 to
have f4 in case of Bishop g5 22 was a
decent alternative to prevent that easy
trade of the bishop it is not just that
this is technically the bad bishop that
that 97 bishop it's also that that black
is having a little bit of a heat is
suffering from lack of space and I don't
want to trade that much Bishop age 6 hmm
interesting interesting decision so
taking 15 is not really great i guess i
can't play that fe Bishop e3 2395 9525
rook air-five 24 looks strange that
looks like it will lose a pawn in the
long run so if you can't if it goes back
I go e5 well it's not such a bad
continuation there's also f5 which
trades the bishop but grabs lots of
space it's not an easy decision both
continuation Shaq both continuations are
probably a good form
advantage yeah yeah simply planning king
age 1g 4g 5 the full-scale expansion on
the King side yeah so what I have to
check in if he is some able to get
something quick I don't think so b5 I
can probably just take that shouldn't be
enough counter play for the pawn yeah
that is an interesting reply i was
thinking about this and after g5 there's
possibly night mmm night h5 naija for
it's not a good idea but night h5 is
interesting so I'm going to going to
cover that the night coming to f6 is
also an indication that is not
supporting this with 97 and be 50 now he
just drops that porn interesting
now Cade will be a bit murky but that's
never going to be enough objectively
don't think so roo k 4i go back to c3
and route somewhere away for yeah that's
not enough compensation really shouldn't
be however of course here i would prefer
to not have my king side we can learn
like that but yeah you can't can't have
it all okay that's interesting but i can
go before here right before 9p 693 back
yeah now okay some getting into
desperation mode but understandably so
it gets some it gets gets tricky of
course so what is this idea Knight b6 or
something like that
now I can go to gay sex now then queen
bee seven I don't get one okay so this
should be okay Queen B seven ok one book
before gate seven I don't believe in
that that looks far too shaky
now probably you should take before
unless there's a clear reputation that
I'm not seeing Queen c3 maybe let's do
this rupee five night whoa what is this
ok so r uu k 8 is not possible what is
the point even here the check on what
exactly Queen B 6 queen of two I don't
don't get it threatening bouquet its own
check check okay time language that we
get to do this with counterplay like
with with a mating attack that's what
I'm trying to say oops too many books g5
is dropping too much stuff and so let's
go here that's actually threatening a
funny made g5 and g6 check funny chick
made I probably will prevent it somehow
i don't see exactly how but that's
probably some way to do it g5 checking
h7 g6 check takes not g5 checking edge
6907 checking h7 okay Jade made that's a
threat check um okay check Wow
okay what now so even a time time
problem check check check check check
check mate ok so to do a recap of that
game yeah i think around here white must
have something with the space but black
hands traded some some pieces so it's
not it's not terrible i believe for him
now a 6g form and he went back here i
was i was expecting something like this
to try to prepare of b5 I mean honestly
I'm not quite sure if it is great but I
mean what I'll quickly with with my
sorry was my expansion maybe now this
this night yeah 11 way to place as
always like this it's also interesting
try to prove that this is sidelined here
night f4 is never really an option
because if we just let susumi place that
here he just has no compensation because
I will get an e5 quite easily or he
plays f6 which is also quite bad in the
game however that was different
different here here here the move Knight
f for me not here probably but in
general is different because here you
might get this blockading square this is
why I was reluctant to push to push g5
it's maybe not bad but yeah I prefer to
play it like this and now we lash out I
really think it's
not enough yeah the engine gives +1 it
shouldn't be enough ready it's always
from practical point of view a bit to be
tricky but yeah now before that that
should be probably winning him yeah it's
plus plus 2 according to the comp yeah I
looking for is a bit a bit of a
desperate move but what I'm threatening
here is simply to play something like
rook be one night back a five and just
push this stuff home I mean he's got no
counter play so I understand that he
wanted to do something but that's
probably not really much going on here
yeah and now he went with this 95 which
is not really working but I was thinking
he should play rugby 5 and go from there
I wasn't completely sure what to play I
was thinking that this is an idea but I
he can actually play this okay so this
is wouldn't have been great this this is
probably running into us of the pin yeah
that was also not great so here I'm not
quite sure the engine gives this move
which is yeah as usual method computer
look pretty strong because here White's
retains control I retain control over c3
so the pawn is not pushed I cannot be
pushed threatening this and Queen a 7 so
when the Queen trade what would win this
very easily yeah that's rather
convincing the way it went in the game I
think he had no compensation what was
cute was one thing check check like him
check let's check but that shake made
was funny oh I can check your meeting
with Luke a shade as that was silly so I
can just check him shake me a shank I'm
sorry 94 checkmate like this that was
silly I was just seeing this because I
spotted that mating idea but yeah you
know him if he goes some night if he
does something
that cave okay Jenna merely stupid yeah
my my idea what Jack was far more
elaborate check check who's this this
China saw this chick made its pretty
typical as you check mail in five but
not achievement in one check anyway
young but sure there's nothing nothing
really happening okay well thanks for
watching